>> Greg: I HOPE YOU DIDN'T
CATCH THAT.
WHEN YOU'RE IN THE MEDIA AND OUT
OF IDEAS, YOU RESORT TO THE
SMEAR AND WITH THE SMEAR OF A
LEADER DOESN'T PROVIDE YOU THE
DOUBLE MEANING HIT, YOU EXPAND
YOUR ATTACKED ANYBODY WHO
SUPPORTS THE GUY.
REMEMBER THE DEPLORABLE'S, A
WORD TO DESCRIBE 60 MILLION
PEOPLE.
WE GOT A NEW ONE TO THOSE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS, THEY SEEM LIKE A
COLD, DON'T THEY?
>> MORE CALLS HAVE BEEN POPPING
UP MORE AND MORE.
TWO WEEKS ON THIS PROGRAM,
ANTHONY'S GARBAGE HE TALKED
ABOUT HIS CLAIM THAT TRUMP
SUPPORTERS ARE IN A COLD.
INCREASINGLY CULTISH.
IN "THE WASHINGTON POST," JOHN
WEAVER SAID THAT THE G.O.P. IS
NOT A PARTY ANYMORE IN THE
TRADITIONAL SENSE, IT'S A COLD.
>> Greg: NEARLY HALF THE
COUNTRY IS A COLD.
THEY BELIEVE IN FREETHINKING,
TRUTH, JUSTICE, IT'S THEIR WAY
BUT USUALLY A CULT IS DEFINED BY
A GROUP THAT DEMANDS LEGIONS AND
SECRETS HE, LIKE CNN.
IT ENCUMBRANCES ANYBODY WHO
DOESN'T WATCH CNN, ALL OF
AMERICA WHO PLUGGED THEIR EARS
AT THE NEW YORK BAR TO AVOID DON
LEMONS WHINING.
WHEN THEY CAN'T EXPLAIN TO
THEMSELVES WHY THEY ARE STILL
LOSING.
MANY SUPPORTERS HAVE MANY
PASSIONATE
MEAT I REMIND YOU THAT 90% OF
TRUMP MEDIA COVERAGE IS AGAINST
HIM FOR ITS LOCKSTEP JOURNALISM.
ONE THAT HAD
DEMANDS ADHERENCE.
>> IT'S LIKE A CULT OF
PERSONALITY.
>> CULTISH DEVOTION.
>> A DESTRUCTIVE CLUT.
>> THE PRESIDENT USING MIND
CONTROL.
>> BECOMING A CLUT.
IT'S FRIGHTENING THAT YOU ARE A
CLUT EXPERT AND YOU SEE ALL THE
SIGNS IN AMERICAN POLITICS.
>> Greg: WHAT DOES THAT SOUND?
LOOKS LIKE YOUR PROGRAMMING
COULD USE SOME DEPROGRAMMING.
THAT'S A GOOD ONE.
NOT AIHARA KRISHNA.
I GIVE THAT ONE TO DANA.
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU THAT I
HAVE USED THIS CHEAP SHOT BEFORE
WHEN I WAS DESCRIBING THE MEDIA
UNDER OBAMA, BUT I WASN'T
DESCRIBING SUPPORTERS, HOW LIKE
THERE WAS AN EIGHT YEAR COMA.
I WOULDN'T GO AFTER HALF THE
COUNTRY WHO LOVED HIM.
>> Dana: ESPECIALLY IF YOU
WANT TO WIN AGAIN.
DO YOU REMEMBER AFTER THE 2016
ELECTION, THERE WAS A SERIES OF
ARTICLES FOR 18 MONTHS WHERE
REPORTERS WENT OUT ON A JOURNEY
TO AMERICA TO TRY AND UNDERSTAND
ALL OF THESE VOTERS.
ESPECIALLY THE VOTERS THAT HAD
VOTED FOR OBAMA AND THEN VOTED
FOR TRUMP.
THAT COMMENT TO ME, THAT IS
ABOUT A CRY FOR HELP THAT WE
NEED CHANGE, WE NEED SOMETHING
DIFFERENT, IT'S NOT ABOUT
BEING -- WHAT IS IT?
WHAT DID HILLARY CLINTON CALL
THEM?
DEPLORABLE PLURALIST
A LOT OF THE CANDIDATES ARE
DOING THIS NOW, ESPECIALLY
MAYOR PETE.
IN ALL HIS INTERVIEWS, HE'S
CLEANLY SAYING, I GET IT, LET'S
TRY TO WORK TOGETHER.
HE'S TRYING TO BE THE PERSON WHO
IS TRYING TO WORK TOGETHER IN
THE PUSH THEM APART.
>> Greg: YOU CAN ARGUE THE
PEOPLE WHO WERE TALKING ABOUT
OBAMA SUPPORTERS BEING CULTISH
ARE MISSING HIS APPEAL AND
MISSING THE REASON WHY HE WON
AND ALL THAT STUFF.
I WOULD SAY IT'S THE SAME HERE,
IF YOU DISMISS SUPPORTERS BEING
CULTISTS, YOU'LL MISS THE REASON
WHY HE WON.
>> Juan: YES.
IF YOU ARE TRYING TO DIMINISH
PEOPLE, YOU'RE LOCKED INTO IT
BUT I DO THINK THERE'S A REASON
THEY ARE SAYING THIS, GREG, AND
IT'S HARD POLITICS.
I THINK IT WAS WASHINGTON
JOURNAL/NBC WHEN THEY DID
POLLING AND ASKED REPUBLICANS,
ARE YOU MORE LOYAL TO THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY OR
PRESIDENT TRUMP, THE ANSWER CAME
BACK MORE THAN 50% SAID MY
LOYALTY IS THE PRESIDENT TRUMP,
BY ABOUT 30% SAID MY LOYALTY IS
TO THE REPUBLICAN PARTY.
THAT'S WHAT YOU SEE A LOT OF THE
TOP REPUBLICANS IN CAPITOL HILL
SAYING WE CAN'T CHALLENGE
DONALD TRUMP BECAUSE TRUMP
CONTROLS THE PARTY.
>> Greg: I THINK YOU ARE
RIGHT.
>> Juan: YOU CAN SAY THAT THEY
ARE ALL ZOMBIES -- NO, I THINK
IT WORKS OUT.
IF YOU ARE 100% BEHIND TRUMP OR
0% BEHIND HIM.
I WOULD SAY TO YOU, TELL ME
THREE THINGS ANYBODY DISAGREES
ON TRUMP ON.
>> Jesse: HE'S GETTING REBUKED
BY REPUBLICANS ALL THE TIME!
HYSTERIA!
DETERRED!
TWITTER!
RHETORIC!
CHINA!
HEALTH CARE!
JUAN, THIS GUY GETS KILLED BY
HIS OWN PARTY CONSTANTLY.
THEY WANTED NOTHING TO DO WITH
THEM BEFORE THE ELECTION!
McCAIN, ROMNEY!
PEOPLE ARE RETIRING LEFT AND
RIGHT!
THIS GUY HAS SOME SORT OF
LOCKSTEP ON THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY?
THIS IS THE ENTIRE REALITY!
>> Juan: LAST WEEK I SAT
THROUGH THE IMPEACHMENT
HEARINGS.
HERE'S WHAT REPUBLICANS SAID.
THE WHISTLE-BLOWER?
NOT HIS FAULT.
THE IMPEACHMENT?
IT'S IN THE LEGAL CREW!
NOT IMPEACHMENT, AND ILLEGAL
CREW!
>> Greg: LET'S NOT TALK ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT, ITS DATA!
>> Juan: THIS IS WHAT
SENATOR KENNEDY OF LOUISIANA
SAID, WE DO NOT KNOW IF RUSSIA
OR UKRAINE >> Jesse: IT WERE
INDEPENDENCE THAT BAILED ON IT!
>> Juan: TRUMP SAYS THE POLLS
HAVE COME AGAINST IMPEACHMENT.
THE POLES HAVE NOT!
>> Jesse: YES THEY HAVE, JUAN.
>> Greg: EMILY?
YOU HAVE EXPERIENCED BEING IN A
CLUT BEING A FAN OF THE OAKLEY
BEHAVIORS
OAKLAND RAIDERS.
TO JUAN '., WHY NOT PLEDGE
ALLIANCE
--
>> Emily: YOU ARE LOYAL TO
PEOPLE, NOT THINGS.
I WAS TAUGHT I WAS IN A CULT
BECAUSE I WAS IN A SORORITY IN
COLLEGE.
>> Greg: YOU DID SLAUGHTER
THAT GOAT.
>> Juan: IT'S CALLED A
SACRIFICE.
AND SHE WAS YOUNG.
>> Emily: IT'S SIMPLE TO
ALIENATE PEOPLE AND WHAT I DON'T
UNDERSTAND IS THE CONTINUED
FAILURE TO GRASP HOW THAT
ELITIST NAME CALLING, TALKING,
PATRONIZING MENTALITY IS EXACTLY
THE REASON WHY PEOPLE WHO
SUPPORT TRUMP FEEL HEARD BY HIM.
WHY THEY CONTINUE TO SUPPORT
HIM, WHY THEY CONTINUE TO FEEL
DISCONNECTED FROM THESE TALKING
HEADS IN THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
AND THE PEOPLE CONTROLLING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
IT IS SO SIMPLE, I DON'T